there are a ton of amazing Donuts in
Asia but my favorite is from Korea where
my family's from my name is Maggie and
I'm gonna show you how to make the
Quebec II when I was growing up and I'd
go to my grandmother's house my
grandmother lives in Korea and so
whenever we visited her she'd bring us
guava key from the bakery food holds
such a big place and in like our
experience of memories but I think like
it just is home you know eating food
from home is like going home but it
never occurred to me that I can't grab a
key in the States and now I can make it
so I might as well just make it whenever
I feel homesick it's gonna be a big
problem for my waistline but I'll be
happier while you're making guava key
you're gonna have to wait a long time to
burn it for the dough to rise and you
know it's just a lot of waiting but
trust me it's worth it
to me being Korean is is the sense of
togetherness especially in the face of
hardship and if you look at Korea's
history we've had a lot of hardship to
overcome it's that sort of tenacity that
really really moved us forward and we
came out stronger every time and I think
that's something that I try to apply to
the way I live too I kept thinking about
this Korean TV show it's like huge in
Korea called Tatanka which i think is
jewel in the palace in english and
there's this character that you know
she's she cooks a lot but I felt like to
dunk them today oh man this is my
favorite part twisting the dough I just
watching it come together just look at
that I love the shape of it it was just
like twisty and it is like both fun to
look at and eat and also just delicious
and it's covered in sugar and you bite
into it it just explodes with sugar and
I remember making a mess and thinking
man I'm gonna get in trouble this is so
much sugar yeah I think my favorite part
is the sugar it's the sugar coating you
know you just pick it up and it's kind
of like fluffy and like when you go at
the right time at the bakery it's warm
too
all I just saw hi my name is Darius and
today I want to show you how to make
chill a bees from India I can't remember
the first time I had delayed me for as
long as I can remember I've had it I
think the first time must have been when
I was a baby
but jalebi has always been one of the
favourite desserts in my family
traditionally jalebis are orange so I'm
gonna use a couple drops of orange food
coloring however if you don't have food
coloring you can use tumeric powder or
you don't have to add food coloring at
all it's pretty common throughout India
and I feel like each region of India has
his own slight version of it but for the
most part what you see is the fried
sticky dough that's crispy but also
really juicy from all the syrup
I remember in New Delhi where I was born
and I lived for a little bit those
stores and they'd be like right outside
you smell it and you say I need it right
now I feel like there's no perfect way
to make the shape you just have to do it
without a lot of space in the middle and
maybe keep it close to the oil but once
we're making right now they're a little
bit smaller than what I usually get well
that one looks like a brain sometimes
they can be as big it's like your face
or something like that they're huge
a lot of times I'll get stuck together
so you'll have like two or three pieces
combined in one you reach the ladies you
get the serum all over your hands and
you have to wash them or wipe them off
and even then it still stays and when
you go home you find in parts of your
shirt you didn't realize it got stuck
too that's just the life of eating
jalebi but it's so worth it
that's delicious my name is Stacy Wong
and I'm gonna show you how to make you
out to you today
I've been eating out to you for 25 years
which is how old I am now my dad would
take me to like little cafes in
Chinatown or even in Hong Kong they just
sell them on the street with like a side
of soy milk or side of porridge we just
eat them together for breakfast it's a
very fun thing to wake up to in the
morning
my family is from Hong Kong so I grew up
speaking primarily Cantonese the way you
pronounce it in Cantonese is yo to you
or there's another way of saying it
where it's like he yells ah quite they
mean the same thing it's the same food
it's just the different ways we call
them so when you're walking down the
streets of Hong Kong it's very very busy
first of all there's always markets up
and down the street there's street food
just being cooked right in front of you
fresh and you can go up to them and for
like a couple bucks get like a full meal
and it's great each stand produces its
own character its own smell it's just
something that you have to walk down the
streets of Hong Kong just to experience
it
I love being from Hong Kong I love the
fact that my family is from Hong Kong
it's like a second home to me and every
time I go back it's almost like a new
world where I just feel like I belong
there I'm hung as such a great country
that has a diversity of people it's like
a Chinese New York almost that's what I
call it a Chinese New York and I love it
I'm using a skier here to make the
little indents on the dough but if you
have a chopstick that only works to the
texture of yo to you is it's kind of
like a mixture of a churro and a very
very fluffy crispy donut the outside is
all crispy and golden brown and then the
inside when you rip it open or you take
a bite into it like very soft and fluffy
so it's just like a world of different
textures crunching together into your
mouth
this definitely reminds me of my younger
self hello my name is Michelle and today
we're going to be making the most
delicious doughnut in the world
my grandmother's SATA andagi from
Okinawa Japan sure as long as I could
remember we've always had sat on dougie
yet like every family function I think I
took it for granted pretty much until I
got to college and I realized oh I can't
just eat it whenever I want my grandma
she adds orange juice to balance out the
flavor so it's a bit more mild lemon
zest is another really common one some
people like to use more purple yam or
purple potato from Okinawa my grandma
though the ones that she makes are more
like maybe ping-pong size or golf ball
size but in Okinawa when you buy
satvinder ghee on one of their busy
streets cooks IOT they're huge they're
super crispy and golden and delicious oh
yes
you